all right so the latest Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania trailer dropped a
couple days ago letting us know that
size does not always matter it's more of
how you use it like like the suit yeah
how how you use the suit but this is
gonna be a full-on data
video covering all of the crazy
outlandish small and big theories we
have for Ant-Man the quantum realm King
and is this all going to be a just a
ripoff of Spy Kids 3D but if you enjoy
this video we'd really appreciate a like
and feel free to subscribe for videos
and other breakdowns every single day
with that out of the way a huge thank
you for clicking this I'm your host to
Jared now let's get into Quantum Mania
alright so things are gonna get trippy
and out there so buckle up but the first
question is why does Kang need Ant-Man
well obviously to steal something boom
done next Theory no it's to steal
something but I think Kanga pulled some
elaborate strings to get him into the
quantum realm first I think Cassie was
actually tricked into making the quantum
realm device shown in the first trailer
she talks to Scott and the others like
they are unaware of it trying to explain
the good that it'll do people still need
help that that's why we made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah so Kang and probably Moda
co-conspired this together to get Scott
into the quantum realm Modoc wanting
Revenge I'll elaborate on him later
because this is just a big headed Darren
cross from what we've seen in this
trailer but Kang needs Ant-Man and his
powers to essentially steal something
again the only reason that he knows
about him and his ability to go
subatomic is because of Darren cross AKA
Modoc anyway Kang wants to strike a deal
with him Kang will send Scott back in
time before he took on the life of crime
and villainy to be a better father and
actually be there with Cassie rather
than setting the role model of a
criminal which Cassie appears to be
following as well I'm pretty sure this
can't happen though because then Scott
will never have become Ant-Man he'll
never meet with the Avengers to discover
time travel it would never end up like
this basically things get real heavy if
we go down that path but Scott doesn't
know this instead going along with
Kang's plan to jump into essentially a
Nexus portal on a cellular level which
I'll touch on later to steal whatever is
powering it so Kang can use this
unlimited power in his time machine
theoretically this battery-like artifact
contains massive amounts of power needed
but also the ability of the Nexus to
create any sort of reality or rather
allow Kang to travel into any sort of
reality at any time some others have
mentioned that it could possibly be the
MCU version of the forever Crystal which
has similar characteristics we can even
see the orb placed in the Kang's time
machine from the first trailer being
very similar to the glowing orb with the
Rings and strange writing similar to
that of the 10 rings that the pile of
Ant-Man are trying to reach in the
second trailer Kang's devices even
shaped like an hourglass hence time
travel baby so I mentioned it a little
earlier but their second trailer shows
us way more of the multiple Ant-Man from
the first trailer even showing Scott
duplicating in real time well this is
because Scott has to dive into a Nexus
portal that is on a cellular level first
of course what the deuce is a Nexus
portal well kind of mentioned in one
Division and Loki as Nexus events and
later expanded on in the Multiverse of
Madness this would be the equivalent to
the Nexus of all realities essentially a
cross-dimensional Gateway that would
provide a pathway to any and all
possible realities and would also
include the element of time and with
this all being on a cellular level this
Nexus Ant-Man dives into is where
timelines are created or in this case
life is created this is why we see
Ant-Man duplicate instantly followed by
thousands of himself trying to obtain
the Nexus artifact Kang is looking for
Kang knows that Ant-Man and his
duplicates can work together like ants
building a tower to reach something
sacrificing himself to save Cassie now
why doesn't Kang just dive in there
himself why wait around for years welp
two things first Kang doesn't 100 know
if this is even safe therefore forcing
Ant-Man into being the lab ant and
second Kane can't afford to have
multiples of himself running around
knowing the way he works and the
backstabbing nature of his variants
mentioned in the finale of Loki this
would be the worst idea Kane could
possibly do now one of the biggest
theories is that Kang is after the 10
rings and Miss Marvel's Bengals because
they are the same Tech that his time
chair and chronopolis appear to be
utilizing that they are missing parts to
his time chair that he needs well that's
not the case instead like I mentioned
the power artifact or maybe even the
forever crystal is the only thing that
Kang needs to get him out of the quantum
realm however with He Who who remains
mentioning the multiversal war that
seems to happen over again and again and
again this would mean that things and
even people hint hint Fantastic Four
could be displaced in time and reality
so I'm saying the 10 rings and Ms
Marvel's Bengals are objects from in the
upcoming multiversal war with Kang and
they were displaced sent flying into
essentially the mcu's version of the
past though they do not actually exist
until the future are you following me
here this is why they have insane
amounts of power they have similar
structure and glyphs that Kang is using
in chronopolis and also Wong and Captain
Marvel say that they don't have anything
that matches this technology it's
because they don't quote technically
exist yet that's why no one has
responded to the 10 Rings Beacon either
potentially Kang is gonna have to gather
these for himself and become more and
more powerful but with that treading the
same Waters of collecting the infinity D
Stones I think the better answer is that
these weapons are going to have to be
used to defeat Kang later this is going
to put some of the Avengers on the same
level as Kang in the upcoming Kang
Dynasty or Secret Wars there are even
some eternals like writing and glyphs
used in the quantum realm so with them
being Advanced their Tech and powers are
going to be able to tie into all of this
as well so no uh Kang is not missing
some hubcabs from his clunky Old Time
Machine another big thing pun intended
is our first look at Modoc with and
without his helmet and yeah this is just
Darren cross AKA yellowjacket from the
first Ant-Man movie this all kinda sort
of makes sense because at the end of
that film Ant-Man messed with his suits
regulator causing him to shrink in on
himself resulting in a huge head right
before disappearing anyway his Origins
are completely different from the comics
but I'm saying that he's gonna be Kang's
right-hand man through most of King
Journey King doesn't necessarily need
him because of his knowledge of
timelines but I think this is going to
be the first step in recruiting baddies
to match up with the Avengers in the
upcoming Secret Wars movie Kang is gonna
meticulously recruit all of these
villains for example Red Skull
potentially killmonger across time and
space to Aid him in the finale of this
Multiverse Saga on top of that this big
Quantum Army Kang and Modoc have
assembled is going to be the real aim
aim standing for advanced idea mechanics
this is something that Modoc has a
connection to Via the comics and is like
in arms dealing science terrorist
organization specializing in futuristic
weaponry and nothing looks more
futuristic than these dudes right here
now sure aim was said to be the company
that Aldrich Killian founded in Iron Man
3 but with him stealing the Mandarin
persona it's not too far off that aim
was also a borrowed idea on his part
this now brings me to the most brutal
scene from the latest trailer you
thought you could win
so does Ant-Man die I'm gonna be honest
I'm very skeptical of death in the MCU
because of the introduction of multiple
timelines and variants I mean does any
of this matter it's like that scene from
beer fest where landfill's brother shows
up to the funeral and just takes over
his role and we move on with the movie
what I'm saying is it's a little
difficult to get emotionally invested in
this stuff but yeah Ant-Man is not going
to make it out of this with his antennae
intact now believe me it's not the scene
from the trailer that we see that's an
entire red herring however phase five
needs to set the stage in a big Way by
doing two things first is showing how
powerful menacing ruthless Kang is going
to be in the next few phases leading up
to Secret Wars like this is going to be
the next Thanos level villain so why not
start him off by squishing Ant-Man well
like like an ant and second this just
proves that none of our big heroes are
safe from in anything even the upcoming
Guardians volume 3 looks like there's
going to be some real loss in that movie
so yeah Ant-Man is done after this
essentially passing on the mantle over
to Cassie to usher in another member of
the upcoming rumored rumored here Young
Avengers that Kevin feige and Marvel are
cooking up lastly the movie is going to
No Doubt no doubt T up and tease the
Fantastic Four with Kang having a direct
connection to Reed Richards and the
quantum realm being involved it only
seems right to at least tease them my
theory is that the same Quantum
satellite Cassie created and used only
for Kang to locate them the Fantastic
Four members will do the same either
contacting Cassie from the same Quantum
realm that they were in or one that is
years in the past you know theoretically
I know time is all different and whatnot
but this will be them coming from the
past knowing of Kang already
urging them of his dangers it would be
wild if they revealed the cast this way
but it's most likely just a wink wink
tease haha here we come anyway we are
roughly a month away from the release of
Kang just laying the smackdown on the
little ant that could so let us know
your hype level of this upcoming MCU
movie and also drop any of your theories
down below we'd love to hear them and
I'll let you know we're currently
running the competition giving away
three copies of Black Adam and Dawn of
the Dead on the 15th of January and all
you gotta do to get a chance of winning
this is like this video subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment Down
Below on your thoughts of quantum Mania
we picked the comments at random at the
end of every single month in the winners
of last month are on screen right now so
if that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other cool videos like our
handful of breakdowns we've just been
cranking out and don't worry four are on
the way so stay tuned but with that out
of the way thank you for your constant
support I've been Jared I'll see you in
the next one take care and peace